[Music]
[Music]
there are so many different angles we
can use
and we always find the evidence for the
existence of black holes
[Applause]
but one thing that's important about
them is that they're utterly different
black hole singularities are completely
wild and crazy
i'm going to try to understand how these
things appear in the universe what role
they have
and most importantly for someone like me
what they teach us about the fundamental
laws of physics
hello everyone and welcome to the black
hole paradox
astronomers last year claimed to have
achieved what was thought
impossible and captured an image of a
black hole seemingly proving the
existence of these
most mysterious objects yet not everyone
is convinced
black holes are so described because
they were proposed as a space from which
nothing could escape not even light at
the heart of the black hole
physics seemed to come to an end its
normal laws and tatters
roger penrose and stephen hawking were
amongst the first proposed black holes
but at the end of hawking's life even he
came to doubt
their existence at least in the sense in
which they were first
described but can we really doubt
something that was predicted not only by
relativity but by quantum mechanics as
well
should we try to hold on to our idea of
black holes however mysterious
and not yet understood that they are
to get to the bottom of what they really
mean we have sean carroll
theoretical physicist and research
professor at the california institute of
technology
roger penrose the mathematical physicist
emeritus professor of mathematics at
oxford
and we have emily santosh professor of
astrophysics at ucl
what is it makes each of you believe so
strongly
in something that we can't see emily do
you want to do you want to go first
yeah absolutely so i'm i'm coming at
this from
an astrophysics perspective and you said
i'm an observer my job is to you know
use big telescopes and look at what's
out there in space and try to
piece together story for how the
universe you know
came to be and evolving to what it is
today and almost
anywhere we look we find evidence for
things that we can't see
but we can see their distinct signatures
if we look
at towards the center of almost every
single galaxy we can see motions of
stars and gas
that seem to orbit at very fast speed
around something that yet we can't see
um and that is some people might see
indirect evidence but still some
evidence for the
existence of black holes then if we look
elsewhere in our galaxy we see
stars that seem to shine so brightly and
that's because they are
you know giant stars orbiting around a
comp and companion that's a black hole
and some very high energy
processes happening there so i think
like in science when you're
thinking about the complex problem what
you do is you approach it from all sorts
of different angles
and in this case there are so many
different angles we can use
and we always find the evidence for the
existence of black holes thank you emily
sean why do you believe in these things
so strongly
it's a great question when i was a
undergraduate i was actually an
astronomy
major in an astronomy department despite
the fact that you know by inclination
i'm more of a physicist
and i became extremely impressed by the
fact that astronomers could collect
little tiny bits of data like the tiny
fluctuations in the light output of a
star and
spin these elaborate tales about what
was going on you know you have a star
that is
pulsating and it's being orbited by a
disk that is tilted
and it seemed like getting something for
nothing but what you realize
is that physics and astrophysics are
very unforgiving
we're given a theory by einstein the
general theory of relativity from
hundreds of years ago and it makes these
predictions and you can test them
against what you see
in a variety of ways and that's the
crucial thing it's not just
that we do one thing and we say yes
we're on the right track
but we do our many little things we do
what emily already mentioned we look at
the centers of galaxies
you can see stars orbiting something
something that is very very massive
and very very small and very very dark
it fits exactly what you would think a
supermassive black hole
would look like but you know maybe it
could be something else
but then you look at other binary stars
where there's stuff accreting onto some
invisible
companion and giving off high energy
radiation again
exactly what a black hole would look
like but in a very different regime
and then you look at gravitational waves
which we just found a few years ago
which turn out to be exactly what
einstein would have predicted over 100
years ago on the basis of his
his equation if you had two very massive
black holes spiraling into each other
so there's this give and take between
theory and observation and the theory is
very unforgiving
it predicts very very certain things and
you see those things
over and over again in different
circumstances and you eventually go you
know
i'm never 100 sure that's not how
science works but i become more and more
sure and at this point i'm so sure that
these things actually exist
with more or less properties we would
expect them to have that i'm just going
to say yes that's what's going on and
i'm going to move on with my life i'm
going to try to understand
how these things appear in the universe
what role they have
and most importantly for someone like me
what they teach us about the fundamental
laws of physics
thanks sean roger why do you believe in
them so strongly
well again the fact that we can't see
them doesn't seem to be much of a
strong case i mean we can't see uh
public 19
viruses we seem to believe in them too
we can if we have appropriate devices
we can't see them directly and so many
things we believe in we don't see
directly
because of black holes it goes back to
chandrasekhar who was a
great astrophysicist and when he was i
think 19 years old
on the boat traveling to england he did
some calculations about white dwarf
stars
and he found out that if they were more
massive than a certain amount they would
collapse
and what happened to them nobody really
knew
and the potential that there might be
something like a bad object
which results from the collapse of a
star has been there for quite a long
time
well it was in 1939 that open hana
and the student of this snyder uh wrote
a paper
on a collapsing dust cloud and
they concluded that this would collapse
down and
make a singularity in the center and a
singularity
would be a place where the density goes
infinite
and the equations go crazy the answer
has equations predict something which
goes crazy in this way
just in the uh early 1960s
you know when when quasars were seen
people worried about these things
because they seemed to be objects that
were um
so massive and so
relatively small that they seem to be
something that would be like
uh what other ham and snyder were
talking about
but there was a big question there
because uh
these assumptions that oftentimes cider
had made
seem that this the thing collapsing was
exactly spherical
and was made of material which had no
pressure
yes as they called it a lot of question
about whether these things were real
and because something irregular
collapsing maybe it would swish around
and come out
at the time this was in 1964 or so
um i started thinking about these things
and uh there was a russian
group who seemed to prove that in the
general case you wouldn't get these
singular states and maybe things with
horror illnesses but then i thought
about this for a while and i was able to
provide an argument of proof
that in the general case as long as you
get beyond a certain point of
no return but they wouldn't necessarily
collapse
and you would necessarily get this
singular state where
the equations were crazy for many years
i think before people
began to take me seriously i think it
was when the quasars were
seen that people began to think maybe
there was something
it could be what we now call a black
hole
what is a black hole yeah we got this
uh wonderful gift 100 years ago from
einstein in the
in the form of the general theory of
relativity right einstein had
10 years prior helped put the final
touches on the special
theory of relativity which says the
speed of light is the speed limit and
things like that
and it was understood that you could
actually think of that theory
in terms of space time being one thing
rather than space and time being
separate so then 10 years later einstein
comes along and says yes not only
is space time one thing but it has a
life of its own
it's curved it's dynamical it can
respond to matter and energy
and it took a long time as roger
indicates for people to figure out that
one possible thing that space time can
do is to curve in on itself
so strongly that there can be regions of
space time from which nothing can escape
you could not leave this region unless
you could travel faster than the speed
of light
and that's what we now call a black hole
and people like roger and stephen
hawking show
that in fact this was very very likely
it was not very hard
to get this kind of thing so really a
black hole is just a region of space
time where gravity has become so strong
whether because a star collapsed or many
stars came together
that once you go in you can never come
out
okay and the wonderful thing about them
one of the many wonderful things about
them
is that there aren't that many you know
if you look at planets
or stars in the universe there's this
wonderful variety of things going on
whereas black holes settle down and once
you know how much mass it has and how
fast it's spinning
you're basically done that is the all
you need to define what the state of the
black hole is
emily i mean what exactly is a black
hole from the from the point of view of
someone who's
trying to understand how how galaxies
and whole collections of galaxies
actually form from an astronomical
perspective at the very
basic level that black hole is very easy
to understand and
roger alluded to that you know we know a
lot about to continue watching this
video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas